und das ist ein Tabuthema und eigentlich
weiß keiner genau warum aber wenn eine
Frau statistisch gesehen sogar jede
dritte Frau ein Kind in der
Schwangerschaft verliert dann ist das
eben kein Thema keines über das man
redet nicht mit Freunden und schon gar
nicht mit Kollegen doch zum Glück machen
sich immer mehr Frauen stark für dieses
wichtige Thema auch Marie nasenmodel
Autorin influencerin spricht jetzt offen
auf Instagram über ihre Fehlgeburt und
wir schrecklich diese Erfahrung für sie
war
2018 hatte ich eine Fehlgeburt und ich
habe damals mein Baby zwischen der
sechsten und achten
Schwangerschaftswoche verloren und wo
man jetzt sagen könnte ach das war doch
noch super früh für mich hat es damals
die Welt bedeutet und ich habe sehr sehr
sehr lange gebraucht um über diesen sehr
schmerzlichen Verlust hinwegzukommen und
damit bin ich nicht allein denn im
Schnitt erleidet jede dritte Frau vor
der zwölften Schwangerschaftswoche eine
Fehlgeburt den Mutterschutz gibt es
allerdings erst ab der 24 Woche man muss
sich also aktuell nach einer Fehlgeburt
erst aufwendig krankschreiben lassen und
ganz ehrlich ich glaube ich wäre dazu
mental nicht unbedingt in der Lage
gewesen ich wollte überhaupt nicht
rausgehen ich wollte mich einfach nur zu
Hause verkriechen mit der Petition
gestaffelte Mutterschutz nach
Fehlgeburten soll das nun zukünftig
Frauen zustehen
mutig und stark wie marinasemann von
ihrer Erfahrung berichteten sie macht
das weil sie auf eine wichtige Petition
aufmerksam machen möchte die Petition
fordert dass es auch bei einer
Fehlgeburt vor der 24
schwangerschaftswoche ein gestaffelten
Mutterschutz gibt das ist also nach
einer Fehlgeburt nicht einfach heißt
Morgen können Sie wieder ins Büro
und jetzt sprechen wie gemeinsam auf ein
Kind freuen gedanklich schon das
Kinderzimmer einrichten für viele Paare
die schönste Zeit aber dann kann eine
Nachricht alles ändern
oft bei einem ganz normalen
Kontrolltermin gibt es kein Herzschlag
mehr man denkt schlimmer kann es jetzt
nicht werden aber dann beginnt er der
Horror wenn sich die Eizelle nicht von
alleine löst muss eine Ausschabung
gemacht werden das heißt ins Krankenhaus
oft auf eine Station mit schwangeren
Frauen die bald ihr gesundes Kind
entbinden dann wird die OP durchgeführt
und danach kann die Frau gehen soll am
nächsten Tag wieder arbeiten als wäre
nichts gewesen so die aktuelle
gesetzliche Regelung wenn man sein Kind
vor der 24 schwangerschaftswoche
verliert also bis zum 6 Monat aber der
Verlust vom eigenen Kind lässt ein
Weiterleben einfach so oft nicht zu und
dann muss die Frau zu Ihrem Hausarzt die
ganze Geschichte und den Verlust des
eigenen Kindes noch mal erzählen und
hoffen eine Krankschreibung zu bekommen
[Musik]
sprechen wir mit der Tasche Sagorski sie
ist Autorin und sie hat diese Petition
ins Leben gerufen die ich bereits
unterschrieben habe und ich hoffe das
ganz viele Frauen ist noch tun jetzt
sind sie waren schön guten Tag sie
nämlich sie hatten eine Fehlgeburt und
nach dieser schrecklichen Erfahrung und
der Ausschabung hieß es für sie viel
Spaß morgen im Büro ab geht's ins Büro
was ging da bei ihnen vor nach dieser
Erfahrung dann diese ich sag's mal
Betreuung zu bekommen
ja das war für mich ein absoluter Schlag
ins Gesicht und ich lag sowieso schon am
Boden ich lag blutend in diesen
Krankenhausbett und die Ärzte meinte nur
Krankschreibung brauchen Sie keine sie
können morgen wieder arbeiten gehen ich
habe immer funktioniert ich bin jemand
ich gehe auch mit Fieber ins Büro und
versuche Projekte zu retten wo es geht
aber in dem Moment ich war sprachlos ich
konnte nicht mehr funktionieren ich
hätte Schutz gebraucht ich glaube so
ziemlich das erste Mal weil ich wirklich
auf Schutz angewiesen und da habe ich
keinen bekommen und ich dachte erst ich
bin ein Einzelfall ich hatte Pech lag an
der Ärztin als ich dann aber ein Buch
jede dritte Frau geschrieben habe habe
ich mit ganz ganz vielen Frauen nach
Fehlgeburten gesprochen und ganz viele
haben mir die gleiche Geschichte erzählt
und da habe ich gemerkt wir haben ein
strukturelles Problem und das kann so
nicht weitergehen was am Ende Mut macht
sie haben zwei gesunde Kinder bekommen
können heute wieder lachen trotzdem
setzen Sie sich dafür ein dass das eben
kein Tabuthema mehr ist was treibt sie
an diese Petition ins Leben zu rufen
also ganz ehrlich ich habe eine gehörige
Menge Mut im Bauch denn ich kriege
wirklich jeden Tag mittlerweile
Nachrichten von Frauen denen ist immer
noch so geht die keine Krankschreibung
bekommen die vielleicht nur zwei Tage
krankgeschrieben werden und die einfach
nicht funktionieren können und es geht
immer weiter immer weiter immer weiter
ich glaube vielen ist nicht bewusst dass
das in Deutschland so läuft bei mir
vorher auch nicht bewusst ich habe mich
auch nie mit Fehlgeburten beschäftigt
warum auch möchte man nicht hätte ich
aber machen sollen dann hätte ich mehr
wissen gehabt und ich glaube
Fehlgeburten aus der Tabuzone zu holen
ist ein ganz ganz wichtiges Thema und
das Frauen diesen Schutz bekommen mit
dieser Petition denn ich glaube ja
Politiker werden nicht morgen aufwachen
und werden sagen oh wir sollten die
Rechte von Frauen nach Fehlgeburten
stärken das wird nicht passieren es gibt
Themen die vielleicht medienwirksamer
und spannender sind für Politiker aber
wir Frauen wir haben auch ein Recht
geschützt zu werden und wenn wir nicht
für uns kämpfen dann wird es keiner tun
und deswegen habe ich diese Petition
gestartet
sie haben mit ganz vielen Frauen
gesprochen haben diese Erfahrung ja auch
selbst gemacht was haben Ihnen die
Frauen geschildert wie sind die damit
umgegangen in so einer Situation in der
man Raum braucht um zu heilen um zu
trauern dann einfach wieder
funktionieren muss was sind die
Schicksale die sie die Geschichten die
Schilderungen die sie da besonders
berühren
also mittlerweile kenne ich wirklich
viele Frauen leider die später depressiv
wurden die einfach ja die dann auch
nicht die Kraft hatten und das kann ich
total nachvollziehen zum Arzt zu sagen
nein ich gehe nicht arbeiten ich brauche
diese Krankschreibung bei mir hat es
dann mein Mann für mich organisiert ich
hatte Glück aber ich hätte es vielleicht
auch gar nicht gekonnt und manche gehen
tatsächlich am nächsten Tag wieder ins
Büro man soll es nicht glauben ja und
dann kommen natürlich im Nachhinein die
Depression nicht bei jeder Frau manchen
Frauen tut es auch gut deswegen fordere
ich ja auch einen ein freiwilligen
gestaffelten Mutterschutz aber man muss
sich das mal vorstellen es gibt Frauen
die sind ja am 6 Monat die sind in der
23 schwangerschaftswoche gehen zum Arzt
kriegen die Diagnose nein das Herz
schlägt leider nicht mehr
kein einziger Tag Mutterschutz am
nächsten Tag wenn vielleicht die
Sprechstundenhilfe einfach eine andere
Termin ausgemacht hat ist Frau geht erst
zum Arzt in der 24 Woche bei 23 + 0 18
Wochen Mutterschutz für das gleiche
passiert es ist eine knallharte Grenze
bei einem so sensiblen Thema und das
dürfte einfach nicht so sein ob diese
Staffelung des Mutterschutzes würde
diese Grenze weicher machen und deswegen
brauchen wir natürlich jede
Unterstützung und jede Unterschrift die
Petition läuft nämlich nur noch heute
wie viel Unterschriften brauchen sie
noch
also wir brauchen jetzt auf der Seite
des Bundestages noch über 20 fast 30.000
Unterschriften bei Open Petition da habe
ich die Petition zuerst gemacht da haben
wir schon die 50.000 geknackt was super
ist ich treffe auch nächste Woche die UV
des Familienausschusses im Bundestag
aber um eine öffentliche Anhörung
wirklich vorm Petitionsausschuss zu
bekommen brauchen wir eben noch mal
diese 50.000 Unterschriften das ist
unglaublich aber es ist leider in
Deutschland sehr kompliziert und
deswegen ja bitte ganz ganz viel
unterschreiben epetitionen vom
bundestag.de nach Mutterschutz suchen
und ja wir haben noch ein paar Stunden
die Stunden werden wir nutzen vielen
Dank dass Sie Ihre sehr persönliche
Geschichte mit uns geteilt haben
Natascha sorgorski und hier noch mal
auch der Aufruf bitte unterschreiben und
diese Petition unterstützen danke Ihnen
[Musik]